[Music]
I think the speed of everything is
increasing a lot with everything moving
towards like a service going to the
cloud and just seeing how we're
democratizing AI and ml so that anyone
can use those to build tools even if
we're not a data science expert
server less stuff in the container stuff
is probably where the future is headed
it removes a bunch of the problems we've
had before so I'm quite excited about
that super free honest progressive web
apps are a great thing as well like I'll
see all the pain of installing and
uninstalling applications is a thing of
the past and that we finally caught up
with what native apps could be do you
think it's exciting that even a broader
set of tools is becoming more easily
available to a broader set of people and
I think that people is under build
things that would seem impossible just a
few years ago in the future quantum
computing even though no one even can
imagine how it works small computers
like these controllers and stuff like
that how to integrate them to more
real-world stuff like this bike I think
it's time for the smartphone to end you
know it really hasn't changed the past
few years it's just been the slab of
flat glass you know more or less since
the iPhone came along I think it's the
visor I don't know if it's hololens are
magically for which one it's gonna be
but that ability to have that knowledge
directly beaming into your eyes for a
device that actually sees your world and
augments it I think that's the next
shift
[Music]